d'autres ont été prises au centre se
trouve surtout le tycoon qui est un
simulateur de youtube heures moules de
te voir bienvenue dans le monde de
youtube merci les gens m'appellent le
prof de youtube
d'après son look sherbrooke on va devoir
choisir entre trois pokéball dans très
peu de temps je vais te guider à travers
ce superbe mondes habités par des
créatures qu'on appelle les youtuber
pour certaines personnes youtube et
juste pour le fun mais d'autres
l'utilisent pour faire de l'argent que
la young boys ou un monde de rêve et
d'aventuré tu attends c'est parti ok
annonce alors on va s'appeler le bon con
voilà notre photo va mettre ça et on est
un homme alors on est une femme on aura
plus d'abonnés sur les décolletés sur
les miniatures [ __ ] à cliquer faut pas
tomber là dedans on est un homme si
répartir diva ok donc là on doit
enregistrer des délais d'esprit pour
voir vos stats et on part avec une
bourse de 100 $ où l'attend c'est
compliqué alors que je peux soit acheté
le skill de faire des blogs soin de
faire des délais de playboy let's play
tout de suite du coup je peux
enregistrer des vidéos sur un jeu
commencer une série bas c'est parti pour
faire une série sur quad ou flavie ba
écoute 26 dollars
elle est cette arnaque ça c'est quand tu
clique sur un lien fait qu'en
commentaires ça je trouve à payer
flambeur 26 dollars aucun d'hachette
floppy birds c'est parti on est en train
d'enregistrer
ça c'est génial c'est trop bien fait 25
vue ok donc tout un groupe de potes du
collège à regarder la vidéo et c'est
bien c'est bon pote
alors on va peut-être faire le deuxième
épisode du couvent une joie hashtag un
l'intérêt à baler dégueu c'est pas mal
on continue c'est ça la vie de
d'enregistrer d'éditer de vidéos là dans
ce jeu est ce que les 25 potes sont
fidèles y en a un qui n'a pas regardé
l'épisode de ça ces mamans salle est
occupée par travaille en ce moment par
contre ce qui est dommage c'est qu'on
fait pas les miniatures parce que là par
exemple pour mes dessins et la tête de
cyprien sera beaucoup plus de vue on
veut tomber dans l'hôpital tout de suite
est-ce que vous continuez cela est
pourri qui bide
bah ouais bah ouais on fait ça par
passion alors on terminera ce jeu aux
changements change cad the string
je pense que c'est on va faire là dessus
c'est parti on a quand même 28 abonnés
et cas et ça c'est quoi on peut
enregistrer le tout dernier épisode
ok on fait ça en fait ça va faire deux
vues immersives vraie maman mais là du
coup on peut choisir un autre jeu
nouvelle série c'est parti ou lac
énergie j'ai pas d'énergie à ok je peux
aller dormir en fait fin du premier jour
a put un atelier de l'énergie pour faire
tes vidéos hockey du coup cette nouvelle
séjour à la ferc de string ces partis
fais moi rêver
bah oui
sa part sur un bazar j'ai informé le
nordmann cyprien label faire du duo avec
moi 84 vue c'est plus que no 3 de notre
quatre premières vidéos réunis et j'ai
un commentaire c'était ennuyant ok
séparables c'était ennuyant mais ça fait
80 cas du alors on va continuer on part
sur un buzz mondial 71 vue pour le
deuxième épisode est franchement on est
pas mal mais dernière épisode [ __ ] on
est bien on est bien on est bien c'est
faux c'est le gros bide pour ce dernier
épisode mais à tous les gens sont lassés
petit à petit on va dormir
est-ce que je peux pas du coût ht
d'eskil haché 1 points à distribuer et
qu'on peut juste le mettre dans les
blogs basique blog on peut faire des
délits blog 4 secondes d'enregistrement
six secondes editing là se baser sur les
vrais temps que tu mets à faire un blog
allez on va parler de cookies au laos en
bas ce texte que j'aime les cookies
attention on se le demande
c'est faux c'est faux ils sont fous
douala sa part sur un bide est-ce qu'on
fait un autre jeu ou pas il nous reste
23 dollars on peut acheter morose partie
alexandra sur un mode sa part sur un
poste à part faire un buzz planétaire sa
part sur une adaptation en film
hollywoodien on va refaire un petit blog
à propos d'une d'une salade sais pas
quoi est ce parti a innové au guide sont
nazes tout votre s'emballer style salhab
nouveau mail ot bravo vous avez passé le
nombre incroyable des 100 abonnés nous
experts ont analysé votre chaîne elle a
été acceptée pour le programme
partenaires de youtube
demain on ajoutera des publicités au
début de vos vidéos ce qui veut dire que
vous gagnerez de l'argent à auxerre 2 au
hockey dans la nuit on a obtenu un point
à distribuer du coup on va faire des
pelles yves logghe voilà ça fait comme
ça on fait beaucoup de vidéo empêchant
on peut mettre un titre
regardez ce que cet homme va faire ça va
cliquer c'est sur brême les gens ils ont
installé un filtre anti pita clicquot
s'il a acquis plus que je fasse elle est
mariée au nouvel épisode va aussi
balancer un nouveau délit vlog un
commentaire alors là le buzz bonjour je
suis une personne comme ça merci pour ce
commentaire constructif
c'est parti pour le petit délai blog
d'aujourd'hui on va avec est ce qu'on
peut mettre comme titre bien plus ta
clique
elle montre ses seins est basée la
lecture là qu'il est vraiment ces titres
là c'est génial on n'était pas loin hier
avec le saint fé sous sl remarque on va
faire morio cadre en fait des gens ont
plus intérêt pour l'expression mais papy
d'un épisode par jour
145 vu oui maman j'aime percée dans le
cube game ok c'est parti pour le
développent une petite routine qui est
pas mal la click & click & click & click
et ça a marché on est maintenant à 120
vue et 133 abonnés part au combat à
moins 4 dollars bon sang mais ce texte
on fera un crédit on expliquera tout à
notre banquier on veut percer sur
youtube décès nous s'il vous plaît sa
part sur un nouvel épisode du spa en
[ __ ] le taux d'intérêt est énorme
c'est faux 60 vue c'est le bide on met
le dernier épisode tout de suite comme
ça demain on commence une nouvelle série
en biologie relancer le let's play morio
230 et une vue et un commentaire bien
mieux que le beurre qu'il ya dans mon
frigo
merci xerox pourquoi je suis au moins 18
dollar j'achète pas de jeu [ __ ] ça
c'est les consos qui prend en boîte là
tous les soirs
ok nouveau jour nouveau des lives log
j'arrête youtube voilà ça fera du coup
on va décevoir d'autant qu'ils sont
abonnés aux mondieux 213 vue et trois
commentaires arrête de ruines et youtube
je n'ai rien trouvé d'intéressant dans
cette vidéo 1 8 pouce vert je vais
abandonner je mets un poteau et je peux
plus aller aux appareils qui volent à
onsan prester 78 pour le deuxième
épisode est franchement j'ai pas mal
même chercheur mais norman cyprien a pu
le faire du duo avec moi je suis sûr
c'est qu'à paba bon [ __ ] mais pourquoi
tu me demande ça au petit commentaire
brahim coucher ça pourrait être bien
mieux ok je vais me suicider
ok aujourd'hui on a fait trois épisodes
du s p on a besoin de saoula va pas se
mentir on amont par femme de dollars ça
y est on tombe dans l'argent on fait
plus ça par passion recommandations user
bidule kouao yakarouler qui a mis un
live sur mes vidéos j'ai gagné 70
abonnés car olek ma vie vient de changer
grâce à toi
actuellement on peut faire des tags avec
d'autres youtuber j'ai dû faire 18 nuits
blanches pour la voir si ça ne clique
pas je tombe malade et ou telle branche
travail lots j'aimerais inviter pour
enregistrer un tag sa vache est ce que
les joueurs apprécieront ce tag hockey
les amis on est maintenant en déficit de
35 $ ont fait deux nuits blanches ne
tienne nous a quittés nous avons changé
de papa je vais me battre pendant des
mois et des mois je vous retrouve juste
après tu es la relève des idiots merci
ça n'a aucun sens d'enregistrer ça
supprime sa chaîne c'est une blague
ce gars est stupide oh tu suces c'était
ennuyant super vidéo l'une de tes
meilleurs
cette nouvelle intro été épique super
vidéo jeux marc ona chaîne ta voix sonne
super bien incroyable super émission
beau travail j'adore ça merci abonnez
vous s'il vous plaît merci vous et moi
les gens après 19 jours sur youtube nous
sommes maintenant à plus de 1000 abonnés
et on a eu quelques commentaires sympas
comme cédé 2 serait beaucoup mieux avec
des chats bah c'est vrai il a raison
désolé c'est de la merde mais il se
sentant qu'on peut s'améliorer donc
c'est cool c'était la plus grande perte
de temps de ma vie mais il sous-entend
qu'il lui reste donc beaucoup de temps à
vivre donc c'est finalement très positif
aussi hommage aussi à prendre cette
vidéo sur tube take où les spurs ne va
plus et cas n'hésitez pas et les vidéos
comme d'habitude je trouvais ça super
sympa malheureusement le jeu est
vraiment à 4% terminé les rendent très
très peu de solutions je pense que tu es
presque obligé de vider la halle aux
toiles devoir regarder portez vous bien
sûr toulouse bis